la gran amenaza de esta región del
noroccidente de ucrania como la ciudad
de luxe que la que nos encontramos si
bien tienen la amenaza de las fuerzas
rusas que las pueden atacar
especialmente con misiles como ya ha
sido sucedió en esta ciudad al comienzo
de la guerra su gran amenaza viene de su
cercanía con bielorrusia donde las
autoridades ucranianas han denunciado
que han habido maniobras militares muy
cerca a la frontera y también cada vez
hay mayor acumulación de tropas esto
porque el presidente bielorruso
alexander lukachenko asegura que esta
cercanía con la frontera con polonia
también cerca de aquí es utilizada para
entrar armas que provienen de la otan y
también a todo el apoyo militar de
occidente lukashenko hablaba hoy de que
occidente podría estar creando una
guerra en el cual ninguno es vencedor y
ellos dice que lo que quieren la otan no
es una omisión y una política defensiva
sino ofensiva atacar finalmente a rusia
y que para eso solamente tiene dos
opciones que son ucrania
bielorrusia esto crea mayor
incertidumbre en esta región del país y
por otro lado en la parte del sur en
gerson la primera ciudad que fue la
primera gran ciudad que fue tomada por
los rusos los ucranianos han iniciado
una contraofensiva dicen que hoy
atacaron un depósito militar donde
habrían muerto 50 soldados rusos desde
moscú se habla de solamente dos personas
mientras en el dónetsk siguen buscando
heridos o personas fallecidas bajo los
escombros van 34 pero hay 30
desaparecidos